اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا
نحييكم الى بانوراما نناقش فيها هذا
المسام ملفين ونبدا بالعناوين
ان المصلحه العربيه تتطلب انه لا يترك
الشان السوري بمفرده هكذا بين ترحيب
وتشكيك سوريا الغائبه تعود الى المنطقه من
بوابه الجامعه العربيه ما مدى استعداد
دمشق للعوده وهل هي ملتزمه للشراطات التي
تضمن لها وللمنطقه مستقبلا افضل
وفي ملفنا الثاني السودان اشتباكات متجدده
رغم الهدى والجهود السياسيه ماذا يريد طرف
الصراع هل سيخضعان للضغوطات ووساطات
التهدئه ام سيدخلان في حرب استنزاف طويله
ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى نقاش ملفنا الاول
سوريا تعود الى المنطقه من بوابه الجامعه
العربيه اعلان استعاده سوريا لمقعدها في
الجامعه فالجرار ردود فعل دوليه متباينه
ومتفاوته بين داعم ومنتقد لهذه الخطوه
واشنطن اعتبرت ان دمشق لا تستحق استعاده
مقعدها وشككت في رغبه الاسد في حال ازمه
بلاده برغم ذلك اوضحت الخارجيه الامريكيه
بانها تتفهم سعي الشركاء للتواصل المباشر
مع الاسد لمزيد من الضغط لحل الازمه
السوريه روسيا حليفه النظام في المقابل
رحبت بهذا الاعلان وقالت ان قرار العوده
سيسهم في تحسين الاجواء في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط اما الاتحاد الاوروبي فلم يحسم
موقفه بشكل واضح المتحدث باسم مكتب العمل
الخارجي الاوروبي بيترستانو اوضح ان هذا
التطور لن يغير موقفا الاتحاد الاوروبي من
النظام في دمشق بمعنى وقالها هذه الجمله
لا للتطبيع الان اما سوريا فاوضحت
الخارجيه السوريه ان دمشق اختلقت باهتمام
من القرار الصادر بعودتها الى مقعدها في
الجامعه العربيه وانها تابعت التوجهات
والتفاعلات الايجابيه التي تجري في
المنطقه مضيحه ان المرحله المقبله تتطلب
نهجا عربيا فاعلا على الصعيدين الثنائي
والجماعي المعرض السوريه ابدت امتعاظها من
القرار من خلال تصريحات متفرقه لاعضائها
فيما رحب مجلس سوريا الديمقراطيه بما وصفه
بالتحرك الدولي بخصوص القضيه السوريه وعبر
المجلس عن امله في ان تساهم المبادره
العربيه في تهيئه الظروف المناسبه لعوده
امنه للاجئين وقال انه مستعد للتعاون في
هذا الشان
الدول العربيه
وليس نهايه للمسار هو تطور ايجابي وخطوه
هامه ربما لا يسعدها هذا القرار العربي
انا مع هذا الاجراء انه يرجع المقعد
السوريين ان شاء الله يعود هذا الموضوع
بالنفق الاقتصادي ولازم ينبني عليها بشكل
صح
نناقش هذا الموضوع وهذه التطورات مع
ضيوفنا من دمشق عمر رحمون المتحدث باسم
المصالحه السوريه من القاهره دكتور محمد
زياد مستشار المركز المصري للفكر ودراسات
الاستراتيجيه ومن لندن
والسياسي السوري اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام
لمناقشه هذه التطورات واسمحوا لي ان ابدا
من لندن معك استاذ فايز استاذ فايز حضرتك
تعلم بانه منذ الاعلان عن هذا القرار
بعوده مقعد سوريا الى جامعه الدول العربيه
كان هناك جدل كبير بخصوص هذه الخطوه ويبقى
من ضمن الاسئله المطروحه هل هذه الخطوه
قادره ان تنهي تماما الازمه السوريه بحسب
اعتقادك
مساء الخير اهلا بك
للجمهور الجمهور المشاهدين والمستمعين
ايضا يعني انا بدي اقول انه
المبادره من حيث المبدا لازم يصير في
تحريك للقضيه السوريه وانا بعتقد انه بعد
المبادره التركيه وبعد الفشل الليمونات
فيه بقايا الجنيف وبقايا استانا المفروض
انه العربي يتحركوا وهذا الشيء يفترض انه
يستعد للسوريين لانه العرب بالاخير هن
حصلوا هون الاخير ان حسن
السوريين الاخير
ولابد انه يتقدموا الاعراب ليقولوا كلمتهم
يوم العرب قالوا كلمتهم الان واي عمل في
فرقاء لازم يكون الفرقاء على نفس المستوى
من التفاعل العرب قالوا كلمتهم انه ترجع
سوريا على الجامعه العربيه لكن شو قال
النظام هذا هو المهم انا رايي كثير كثير
مهم انه نوقف عند سؤال هو قال انه نتابع
باهتمام
بعدين انه هاي راح تحسن العلاقات بين
العرب كلهم لا بين العرب مو هيك وهن مو
باهتمام هذا بيحكيه واحد مراقب يعني اذا
طلعت قبرص وقالت او مدغشقر او او هونغ
كونج اي كلام يعني بيطلع بيقول انه عم
نتابع باهتمام الامريكان الاوروبيين الروس
كلهم قالوا رايهم انه وين بتروح حي الا
صاحب العلاقه صاحب العلاقه المتابع
بالتمام
في الواقع استاذ فايز هو بالاساس هل
الاولويه ان تعادل علاقات بين سوريا
والعرب او ان تعادل علاقات في مرحله اوليه
بين السوريين والسوريين وهنا سؤال حضرتك
استاذ عمر سوريا الى اين سوريا بكل
انقساماتها وبكل الاطراف الموجوده فيها
على الارض سواء عسكريا او الاط راف
المقسمه على المستوى السياسي هل هذه
الخطوه ستحل الازمه السوريه باعتقادك
تحيه لك ولضيفك واستاذ المشاهدين
دون شك يعني عوده سوريا جامعه الدول
العربيه هي دافعه اساسيه ورئيسيه لاصلاح
ما فسد خلال الازمه السوريه يعني البعض
يريد القطيعه مدى الدهر والقطيعه بحياتها
يعني نحن عندنا مشكله في سوريا هذه
المشكله وهذه الازمه ترتب عليها ازمات
ومشاكل كانت الضرر فوق السوريين الان
الضرر فوق السوريين وفوق العرب طيب حل هذه
الازمه بالاساس وحل الازمات المترتبه
عليها لابد من التواصل فالتواصل هو امر
طبيعي لحل الازمات سواء الازمه الاساسيه
او الازمات
كانت هناك فيما قبل حلول كانت هناك
المبادره العربيه وعلى اثر عدم التزام
النظام السوري بهذه المبادره تقرر وقتها
في 2011 استبعاد سوريا من جامعه الدول
العربيه بالاس اس بخصوص هذه المبادره ما
الذي تغير
وان كنت تقرا ان كان هناك موقف سوري جديد
فيما يخص اي مبادره عربيه هل تقرا ذلك
يا سيدتي العشر سنوات الماضيه التي مضت
كان هناك رياح ما يسمى بالربيع العربي
وكان لتنظيم الاخوان المسلمين الكلمه
العليا فيما فيما جرى الان الذي اقراه هذا
السؤال يوجه للجامعه العربيه ما الذي
قراته الجامعه العربيه بعد عشر سنوات التي
اخرجت سوريا ثم الان رفع التعليق العضويه
واعادت سوريا الى جامعه الدول العربيه هذا
السؤال يوجه في الحقيقه للجامعه العربيه
ولا يوجه لنا كسوريين او لا يرجى حتى
لسوريا هناك قناعه عند الجامعه العربيه
يتكونت بان خروج سوريا امر دار وبان
الابتعاد عن سوريا اضر المصلحه العربيه هل
هل من مصلحه العرب ان يكون هناك احتلال
تركي دوله عربيه هل من مصلحه العرب ان
يكون هناك احتلال امريكي لدوله عربيه هل
مصلحه العرب ان يكون هناك قوى حتى وان
جاءت بطلب من الحكومه السوريه كاروسيا
وايران مثلا هل من مصلحه العرب ان يكون كل
هؤلاء موجودين على الاراضي السوريه هل هل
من مصلحه العرب ان يكون هناك استانا
وسوتشي وتحضر ايران وروسيا وتركيا ولا
وجود للعرب اطلاقا العرب اقتنعوا بان هناك
مفسده كبيره باخراج والبعد عن سوريا
وتركوا المجال الروسي والايراني والقريب
والبعيد فعوده سوريا هي مصلحه عربيه
او البحث
هذا السؤال دكتور محمد زيد دكتور محمد
اسباب استبعاد سوريا يقول البعض لا زالت
قائمه ليس هناك التزام بتنفيذ ما اتفق
عليه طيله الاثني عشر سنه السابقه ضيفي
الاستاذ عمر يطرح تساؤل يقول بانه علينا
ان نفهم من الجامعه العربيه ان كان هناك
تغير لحظات او حسابات جديده فرضت على
الساحه الاقليميه
لاعاده مقعد سوريا حضرتك هل ترى شيئا تغير
حتى تعطى هذه الفرصه لسوريا وبايه شروط
كذلك في المقابل
نعم تغيرت اشياء الاطراف التي كانت تضغط
على الحكومه السوريه من 2011 و12 و13
وكانت تستهدف اسقاط النظام السوري بالدرجه
الاساسيه تغيرت الواقع الاقليمي تغير
الجامعه العربيه التي كانت تعاني من ضعف
شديد ولا حضور لها في اي ملف ملفات
الازمات العربيه حتى تاريخه بدات تتفاعل
مع الازمات
وتتحرك وتتخذ قرار ولجنه اتصال فيما يتعلق
بسوريا وفيما يتعلق بالسودان هذا كان امر
مفتقدا حديث السيد الامين العام منذ سته
شهور ليس حديث الامين العام اليوم لماذا
لان هناك دول اقليميه او دول عربيه كبرى
وجدت ان استمرار الابتعاد العربي عن سوريا
وعدم
عودتها للحضن العربي ساعد على تموضع قوه
اقليميه اخرى تهدد الاستقرار في المنطقه
وساعد على تصعيد المواجهه ما بين تلك
القوه واسرائيل ويدفع تدفع سوريا الثمن
بهذه الخطوه التي تمت هي الخطوه الاوليه
وعلى الحكومه السوريه ان ترد بالخطوات
المطلوبه منها لتفعيل ما تم الذي تم حتى
الان هو تصحيح الموقف الجامعه العربيه من
التعامل مع سوريا ومع الازمه السوريه التي
غبت عنا فترات طويله وعان على الاستقرار
في المنطقه من هذا القرار ولكن ما الذي
تقصده فقد دكتور محمد لما تقول على
الجامعه العربيه تصحيح الموقف ان تصحح هي
موقفها او ان تطالب النظام السوري ان يصحح
هو موقفه فقط هذه الجزئيه لافهم
لا طبعا بالتاكيد هتطلب في مطالب متعدده
للحكومه السوريه مطلوبه يعني القرار
الجامعه انهى موقفا سلبيا للجامعه هل
انتهى الموقف المقاربه الخاصه بالجامعه
الذي يترتب عليها تقديم نقاط او تقديم
يعني اجنده كامله مطلوبه من الحكومه
السوريه للتوافق مع الخطوه التي اتخذت في
هذا الشان طيب استاذ فايز في الواقع لما
نتحدث وتعلم حضرتك باننا عند حديثنا عن
سوريا نتحدث عن شقين هكذا فرضت سنوات
علينا نتحدث عن النظام ونتحدث عن المعارضه
طيب المعارضه اليوم تقول بانها ممتعضه من
هكذا خطوه
لماذا هي ممتعضه والبعض يقول بانه ان كان
بشار الاسد خيار سيء فانت المعارضه قد
تكون الخيار الاسود لانها طيله سنوات مع
كل الدعم لم تجد لنفسها مكان فهي ممتعضه
من ماذا في النهايه
انها تمترض من هذه المواقف لانه هي
بالاخير عندها موقف عدائي شديد العدائي
النظام بفعل ما ارتكبه من جرائم
ضد السوريين وضد العرب اذا حبيتي واذا ضد
العالم لانه جرائم النظام ممتده من داخل
سوريا الى خارجها لكل العالم هدول الدول
اللي اخذت لاجئين غصب عنها واللي بتقدم
مساعدات اليوم
هيتعاقبت بفعل سياسات النظام في تطفيش
السوريين وقتلهم ودفعهم للهجره اذا
المعارضه طبيعي انها تعترض وطبيعي انها
تقول لا ما عجبنا بس مع ذلك انا بعتقد انه
المعارضه لازم تفهم انه بالاخير الدول
العربيه لازم تتحرك وفق رؤيتها كمان يعني
احنا اذا كنا بنعترض او منحب هذا موضوع
ثاني بخصها احنا بس لازم نشوف بشكل موضوعي
مصالح صحيح تقول بان المعارضه عليها ان
تفهم جميل بان تفهم ولكن قد يقول لك البعض
استاذ فايز بانه
ان تفهم ولكن لماذا اخفقت المعارضه في ان
تقدم حل بديل بمعنى انو طيله سنوات لم
تقدم حل بديل على الاقل بتاريخ الخمسين
سنه الماضيه اللي انا عايش فيهم معارضات
من مختلف البلدان ما في ولا معارضه
استطاعت ان تحدث تغيير في بلد ما في بلد
ما دون مساعده من المجتمع الدولي او من
دول جوار او شقيقه او الى اخره هاي القصه
معروفه لذلك يعني لا حدا يطلب من المعارضه
وخاصه ازاء نظام قاتل ازاء نظام قارن اذاء
نظام
متاسس بالامن عايش خمسين سنه لا حدا يطلب
من المعارضه انها تقوم بما نفعل لا يفعله
غيرها لازم كان وهاي مطلوبه ومشان هيك عم
اقول لك انه كانوا العرب وما زالوا العرب
هم سندوا السوريين وكثير كان موقف العرب
لما واليوم دائما موقف العرب المفروض انه
يدعم حقوق الشعوب حقوق الشعوب من اجل
الحريه من اجل الكرامه من اجل الحياه افضل
لكن هو حضرتك تتكلم هناك عدم قبول لهذا
الراي من الاستاذه عمر استاذ عمر ضيف يقول
بانه حتى وان كانت المعارضه هزيله في
مردودها في ادائها ولكن لا يستحق بشر
الاسد هذا المقعد لانه ارتكب من الجرائم
ما ستبقى عالقه في كل الاذهان ما رايك
سيدتي يعني نحن امام واقع جديد
المعارضه كانت تريد اسقاط الدوله واسقاط
النظام بالقوه المعارضه ومن يدعمها لكن في
الحقيقه باءوا بالفشل جميعا سواء كانت
المعارضه او حتى الدول التي تدعم هذه
المعارضه طويله هذه الصفحه سوريا بقيت
كدوله والرئيس بقيت كرئيس نحن مع استقبال
النازحين بعود
الوضع
سندخل في هذا التفاصيل ولكن حضرتك تقول
سوريا تبقى سوريا طيب خلينا نفصل هالموضوع
معك نتحدث عن سوريا منطقه شمال الشرقي
تسيطر عليها قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه من
الحسكه للقمش لوصولا لحدود الرقه والزور
نتحدث شمالا عن مساحات شاسعه من حلب ادلب
تسيطر عليهم المعارضه وكذلك اجزاء شاسعه
في ريف حمس والباقي للنظام عن اي سوريا
نتحدث المقعد من سيجلس عليه
يا سيدتي هذا الذي نراه اليوم هو ما فعلته
المعرض بالدوله هذا ما نراه اليوم هو
نتيجه العدوان الدول التي دعمت المعارضه
لاسقاط الدوله الان بقيت الدوله وبقيت
مؤسسات الدوله هناك مناطق محتله ثم
المعارضه ما الذي فعلته المعارضه سوى
تحطيم الدوله والهجوم على مؤسسات الدوله
والاتيان بالاحتلال الاحتلال الامريكي جاء
على اكتاف المعارضه الاحتلال التركي جاء
على اكتاف المعارضه الان مهمه الدوله
اخراج الاحتلال التركي والخراج الاحتلال
الامريكي واصلاح ما افسدته المعارضه نحن
نقول هذه المرحله عشريه الدم طويت صفحتها
سواء رضيت المعارضه او لم ترضى بقيت
الدوله بقيت الجيش بقيه المؤسسات نبحث عن
اصلاح ما افسدته المرحله التي ارادت
المعارضه كسر الدوله فيها بالقوه وازاحه
الرئيس وازاحه النظام بالقوه والان هي هي
بدايه كما قال الامين العام عوده سوريا
الدول العربيه هي بدايه مسار وليست نهايه
المطاف هناك كثير من الشروط والمطالب لدى
سوريا هناك كثير من المطالب لدى العرب هذا
كله لا يمكن ان يحارب جلسه او بقرار عوده
سوريا
احمد مساو حتى حتى السفير احمد ابو الغيط
قال هذه الخطوه هي بدايه وليست نهايه
المطاف ولكن دكتور محمد استمعت لضيفه هو
يقول بانه الان مرحله جديده والنظام
السوري قادر ان
يبعد عن سوريا شبح الاحتلال التركي
الايراني وذكر ما ذكر هل تعتقد الدكتور
محمد بان سوريا قادره على ذلك بان هذا
المقعد مقعد سوريا بالجامعه العربيه سيكون
خالص من اي تاثيرات دوليه واقليميه
يعني هو الدعوه وجهه الحكومه السوريه
الحكومه الشرعيه فالمقعد للحكومه الشرعيه
فيما يتعلق بالشرق والموجود فيه احتلال
امريكي
والحكم محاوله انشاء حكم ذاتي كردي هناك
حوار ما بين النظام في الاسابيع الاخيره
وما بين تلك القوه على ان يبحثون عن صيغه
تعود فيه الاكراد الى الى الحكومه
المركزيه بشروط ربما تكون شبيهه بالنظام
السياسي الموجود في العراق الحديث عن
المعارضه في الشمال حديث غريب للاكل ما هي
المعارضه اللي في الشمال من يتزعمها
الجولاني الذي يسيطر على ادلب ولا القوى
العسكريه الفصائل العسكريه التي استخدمتها
تركيا كمرتزقه في ليبيا اين منصات
المعارضه التي كنا نسمع عنها السياسيه
منصه القاهره ومنصه الرياض ومنصه الدوحه
الوجود
العمود الفقري للمعارضه كما يبدو ادام
امام الاوروبيين والغربيين هي القوه العسك
وبالتالي انا اعتقد ان النظام عليه ان
يبدا خطوات فعليه
لتطمئنه القوى السياسيه المعارضه المعتدله
وان يبدا هذا الكلام باجراءات تزيد من
شرعيته
وتؤكد ان الموقف العربي كان ايجابيا يبدا
باملا بالسماح بعوده النازحين دون مسائله
ودون اجراءات امنيه ويبدا بالافراج عن
المعتقلين والبحث عن المفقودين كل هذه
اجراءات اسمها اجراءات تحقيق الثقه
المبدئيه يومها ربما تسمح القوى المعارضه
السياسيه بالتحديد وليست الفصائل العسكريه
بان تجري حوارا مع النظام
سيد فايز هل تعتقد بان النظام السوري قادر
ان يلتزم بمثل هكذا نقاط
كمبادره حسنيه ومن الجانب الاخر كذلك هل
ترى بان المعارضه قادره ان تتلقف مثل هكذا
فرصه
هلا انا بعتقد انه فكره المطالب هي
المطالب الطبيعيه اطلاق المعتقلين عوده
اللاجئين اللي هي لا يمكن انها تكون شروط
اي المفروض انها تتم بشكل اعتيادي وطبيعي
وسواء مشينا بالسلام او مشينا بالحرب بغض
النظر اذا هاي لازم ترجع اللاجئين يرجعوا
على بلدهم ولا معتقلين بيطلعوا لاهلهم هذه
طبيعي هلا النقطه الثانيه نقطه الاجراءات
هاي الاجراءات اللي غير هدول النقطتين
المفروض فعلا مثل ما قال ضيفك من القاهره
انه يتحقق هذا الشيء لانه يطلع يطلع بيان
يطلع تصريح واضح انه الحكومه السوريه
حكومه النظام تطلع تقول انه احنا رايحين
احنا رايحين على تسويه وعلى اصلاح على على
اجراء متغيرات تضمن تجاوزنا 12 سنه من
صراع ضد الشعب السوري واحنا راح نحل مشاكل
اما انه يطلعوا ويقولوا انه عم نتابع عم
نتابع هذا الحكي يعني صراحه واكثر من هيك
احنا ما عندنا بحاجه لفكره التحليل فكره
التحليل صارت كل واحد معروف على مستوى
العالم صرنا عشرين 12 سنه احنا وعم نحلل
ونناقش ونفصل بالموضوع السوري اللي مطلوب
هو فعلا اجراءات عمليه شو بدنا نساوي
العرب طلعوا قالوا شو بدهم من النظام
الاتراك الاتراك طلعوا وقالوا شو بدهم من
النظام حتى الان ما في اجراءات عمليه
تصريحات واضحه من النظام اسال بخصوص هذه
النقطه الاستاذ عمر استاذ عمر بحسب
تقديراتك وبحسب قراءتك للاوضاع لماذا لم
يصدر حتى الان بيان من النظام السوري يحدد
فيه موقفه بطريقه واضحه صريحه يحدد فيه ان
كانت هناك شروط كانت هناك اجراءات سيلتزم
بها هو يتابع والمتابعه على فكره تفتح
المجال الشكوك وتتذكر معنا حضرتك وكنت
حاضر معنا في حلقات سابقا بانوراما
وناقشنا عوده العلاقه التركيه السوريه ولم
يكن كذلك هناك موقف واضح والبعض قال بانه
النظام التركي
رهينه تاثيرات او رهين تاثيرات ايرانيه
هذا الصمت بما يفسر
هو ليس صمت بمعنى يعني المعارضه تريد ان
تقول بانها تريد ان تسمع تصريحا من الدوله
السوريه انه سيرحل الرئيس بشار الاسد بعد
غد وعلى المعارضه ان تاتي وتستلم كرسي
الرئاسه في سوريا هذا ما تريده المعارضه
سيد عمر اليس هذا حقهم لانه هذا الموضوع
طرح منذ سنوات بان يكون هناك تعديل
للدستور بان تكون هناك اجراءات سياسيه
انتخابات
المعارضه المعارضه كما تفضل ضيفك من
القاهره لم يبقى هناك من المعارضه
العسكريه الا المعارضه المتطرفه التي
يحكمها الجولاني والقاده القاده الفصائل
الذين يشتغلوا مرتزقه وباقيه المعارضه نحن
انا انا الان احدثكم من دمشق انا معارضه
وطنيه مع معارضه تحترم الدوله تحترم
مؤسسات الدوله تحترم الدستور لكن لسنا ما
معارضه تابعه لهذا لهذه السفاره او انا
اريد ان احدث التحدث عن نقطه نحن مع طي
صفحه الماضي مع فتح صفحه جديده وتوضيح
ماذا تريده المعارضه هل بقيت المعارضه في
حلم 2011 هل بقيت المعارضه مصره ومتقوقعه
في دائره ضيقه الا وهي اسقاط النظام
واسقاط الرئيس واسقاط الجيش ام اقتنعت بان
هناك متغيرات حدثت وان عليها ان تغير من
سياستها من خطابها من من اذاها المعارضه
حتى الان هي تعيش في حلم لم تتغير ابدا
كما انه يطالب النظام ان يطور وان يعلن
وان يقول ماذا يريد الدوله السوريه الان
محاصره باحتلالات باحتلال امريكي احتلال
تركي محاصره بقوه داعشيه جبهه تنظيم
الاخوان المسلمين هل يعقل ان نطلب من هذه
الدوله التي تعاني الامرين امرين الحرب
انت ان نقول
لابد من من وضع خطه تتوائم مع الامكانيات
ما هو الممكن لسوريا اذا اردنا ان نحافظ
على سوريا على وحده سوريا على مؤسسات
سوريا ماذا يمكن ان نفعله الان المعارضه
لا حديث لها الا باحلام 2011 وهذا شيء
انتهى لم يعد
تعليقك استاذ فايز خلينا نسمع احلام
المعارضه حكامنا عنها الاستاذ الاستاذ عمر
حكى لنا عن احلام المعروضه خلينا نسمع
احلام النظام نفسه شو بده
يقول لنا شو بده راح يرجع يطلع حدا يقول
لنا انه راح نرجع اللاجئين يطلع حدا يقول
راح نطلق سراح المعتقلين هاي ما فيها شروط
هي يفترض انه يساويها عادي ما يساوي حدا
عليها اكثر من هيك بدي اقول لك لازم
الاستاذ عمر اذا كان ما بيعرف
مستوى المسؤوليه عند المعارضه ومستوى
المسؤوليه عن النظام لازم يروح يقرا شيء
عن الدوله
عن سياسه الحكومه عن مكانه الحكومه عن
مكانه الدوله في المجتمعات لازم يروح يقرا
شيء لانه بالاخير ليست المعارضه معارضه
اسمها معارضه الحكومه اسمها اداره
اسمها قوه قوه التاثير قوه القانون هيك هي
هيك هو بيقول ولكن لماذا تنتقد كلامي
استاذ فارس
في ظل الفرق وين مسؤوليه الحكومه
والمسؤوليه المعارضه هو يقول بانه
المعارضه فشلت في طرح اليه في طرح اسلوب
في ان تكون بديل حقيقي جدي فشلت طيله اكثر
من عشر سنوات هو هذا ما يقوله الاستاذ عمر
نعم نعم
يقول فشله النظام اللي ما فيه شيء حسب
قوله والنظام اللي انتصر حسب
اللي ما بيقدر يميز بين الاحتلال اذا كان
ايراني وروسي عن الاحتلال الامريكي
والتركي
وهذا النظام المفروض يطلع يقول لنا شو هو
الاستاذ عمر
من تحليل
المعارضه بعد 12 سنه اثبتت للعالم كله انه
لا يوجد بيدها اوراق الان الجامعه العربيه
قررت ان تعيد سوريا ماذا بيد المعارضه ان
تفعل ليس بيد المعارضه شيء المعارضه خسرت
كل شيء حتى خسرت جمهورها الجمهور المعارض
الان الله وكيلك يوميا تاتينا كثير من
الطلبات الناس بدها ترجع تعمل تشويه
للمصالحه باب الدوله مفتوح لكن تركيا هي
التي تمنع النازحين من العوده الى الى
مناطقهم
هناك قوى لانه ايه ايه لانه لانه هاي
مبالغات اتحدث
ليست يا استاذ يعني
اتحداك على التلفزي ون العربيه ان تحدث
لحظه لحظه
كلمه لكل استاذ عمر تعليق باختصار شديد
قبل قبل ان اختم معك استاذ فايز
صفحه العشريه السوداء انطوت عادت سوريا
الى جبهه الدول العربيه سوريا بالجلوس مع
الدول العربيه سيتم حل ملف النازحين
باختصار
لبنانيين صرنا شهرين عم بدهم يطردوا
السوريين خليه يطلع النظام يقول احنا من
ارحب
بمواطنيننا بلبنان ورحت رسالة حضرتك
اسمحوا لي اسمحوا لي ان اكتفي بهذا القدر
والاكيد باننا سنكون في متابعه لكل هذه
التفاصيل وتطورات شكرا على المشاركه من
دمشق الاستاذه عمر رحمون المتحدث باسم
المصالحه السوريه من لندن والسياسي السوري
واشكرك واعتذر منك كذلك على ضيق الوقت
الدكتور محمد زياد مستشار المركز المصري
للفكر والدراسات الاستراتيجيه والاكيد
باننا سنكون في نقاشات اخرى شكرا لكم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات